we work we work in an industry that is
the most competitive industry that's
ever been created in the history of the
world if let's just look at energy
efficiency just to put this in context
right in energy efficiency a computer
today is about three million times more
efficient meaning the amount of
computation it can do for watt of power
consumed as it was when it was developed
60 years ago on 50 years ago there's
nothing else that we can name in any
product category that's even ten times
so you're looking in an industry that is
orders of magnitude of moving moving
faster in terms of its innovation that
any other industry that's ever been
created so you say well so you know how
do you go manage that how do you go deal
with that you know it's kind of a it's
kind of a self self-preserving prophecy
if you're not doing the research and
development it you're not going to be
able to stay competitive with a person
or in another country that is and you
just got a business so rd for us in that
kind of passionate development of both
the two main main parts of what we do
one of which is building a better and
better transistor that's called the
process and one of which is they're
putting those transistors together in
more and more clever and hopefully
innovative ways IE how you build a
microprocessor how you build a chipset
how you build graphics how you build
consumer electronics how you do any of
the things that you do with in those two
major areas you know we've we have
invested through every recession we've
invested we will continue to invest
through this economic crisis
well first of all I don't know what's
going to happen to our business right
well you know I can tell you a year from
now how our business feared through the
through 2009 we don't know today
fundamentally businesses are to meet the
needs of consumers and whether that
consumer be another business whether it
be a government whether it be you know
you know someone looking for a pc for
their child or someone trying to buy a
bicycle it you're trying to meet the
need the way you grow businesses by
meeting those needs better than the
other guy it's it's sometimes it just
gets down to nothing more than that so
if the if if you're in if you're in
markets that are that are shrinking then
you're going to certainly take you're
going to shrink along with that market
in the short term and then you have to
make sure that you then use a full
complement of technologies to hopefully
build other products than in related
industries and you know I think that's
the work that we've been trying to do in
in a number of different areas that
lattice five using